je crois qu'il est on peut aller au
cinéma différent de commander un film
oui mais pas frontalement serre qui il
peut être fait évidemment et il a menti
quand il peut émouvoir quand ils peuvent
fait rire quand il peut susciter donner
une émotion et dire des choses alors là
pour le pouce c'est formidable c'est le
rêve de cloche je pense je radote nature
je pense qu'un jour un film sera
tellement beau tellement réussi que deux
heures il pourra changer beaucoup de
chose j'sais pas si changera le monde
mais en deux heures on peut avec un film
parfait
faire gagner beaucoup de temps aux gens
vivant non mauvais il a d'abord dit
de nombreux cinémas donne à réfléchir et
serait aux politiques qu'il faudrait
poser cette question je crois au pouvoir
du cinéma pour changer le monde pour
dire le monde pour imaginer un monde je
crois d'une manière générale en la
nécessité de ce que disent et de ce que
sont les artistes et c'est pour ça aussi
qu'il faut sans arrêt ne pas oublier
qu'ils aient des artistes qui parce
qu'ils créent sont emprisonnés et sans
bâillonner la force des images peuvent
changer des choses oui même si c'est
très très idéaliste mais oui oui quand
même j'en suis persuadé et je pense que
même au delà de ça je pense que
l'éducation à l'image et aussi la main
peut changer les choses c'est à dire que
c'est un apprentissage qui doit se faire
dès l'école pour ne pas être passifs
devant les images mais pour vraiment les
saisir